I will save the webserver.py file,
navigate to it
from within my Vagrant machine, and
execute it writing python webserver.py.
The Vagrant environment for this course
is already configured to forward port
8080 requests from the host machine
to port 8080 on the Vagrant machine.
So if we open up a browser and visit
the URL localhost8080/hello look, our
server recognized the GET request and
responded with the code that we wrote.
>From the Vagrant machine, we can also
see the GET request it received from
the browser and
the code we sent as a reply.
Try and create this code on your own.
If you run in to any problems, a
functioning version of this python code,
can be found in the instructor notes.